o psol se organiza mais um vídeo e hoje
vou ensinar como fazer um carinho
telecomandado estudo foi patrocinado
pela loja bangu que forneceu os
componentes eletrônicos
eu gosto deste componente é que vocês
podem usar em vários projetos
ou seja eu vou fazer esse carrinho e
passado algum tempo quando já estiver
faro brincar com o carrinho ou literal e
usarem outro projeto no canal vocês vão
verificar que vou usar sempre os mesmos
componentes por fazer diferentes
projetos
os links dos por último está na
descrição deste vídeo
agora se vocês não quiserem gastar
dinheiro não puderem podem sempre tentar
utilizar um carrinho e vocês tenham lá
em casa variados e usei por servo o
motor que vai dar velocidade ao carrinho
a placa de controlo e depois o movimento
precisar do comando e as baterias claro
se você estiver na parte eletrônica o
resto vai ser bastante simples uma vez
que eu tentei utilizar coisas que toda a
gente em casa com um papel cola quem
podem usar cola normal se não tiverem
cola quente fita política lep lei do
churrasco em coisas que vocês já viram
aqui na vossa tela é bastante simples
assim
agora só é propiciar o vídeo
o
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
já a a
ah ah ah ah
ó
háháhá
o processo - o fio teria encostado e
entendendo assim poucos livro mas estou
a pensar fazer um vídeo que vai demorar
um pouco irritada explicar o que
aconteceu é e fiquem atentos ao canal
que agora vou começar a postar mais
frequentemente eu ache muito obrigado
ter existido até a próxima
tal